hi Matt here with a quick reminder that
our free virtual think fast talk smart
live event is coming up on December 13th
at 8:00 a.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific we
already have over 1,200 people from 65
countries registered join us for some
fun learning and prizes I'll be
discussing some specific techniques you
can use for clear concise and compelling
communication and then I'll take your
questions we'll be making an episode out
of this live event so you might get to
hear your voice on the podcast sign up
at faster
smarter. hi Matt here our mindset has a
big influence on how we experience our
world a while back I spoke with Aaliyah
crom about the impact of mindset on our
communication and confidence among many
other topics I found our discussion
about reframing anxiety really
interesting and many listeners have told
me that this was super impactful for
them so I invite you to listen in to
this think fast talk smart best of
episode with aiyah crom on
mindset mind control was my favorite
class in college in it we learned the
tactics and theories others Ed to
persuade us later I learned that while
other people can be influential in
changing perceptions attitudes and
behaviors some of the most effective
influence actually originates from
within
ourselves hello I'm Matt Abrahams and I
teach strategic communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business
welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast today I am super excited to
speak with Aaliyah Crum Aaliyah is an
assistant professor in the Stanford
psychology department where she is the
principal investigator of the Stanford
mind and body lab Aaliyah's research
explores how changes in subjective
mindsets can alter objective reality
through behavioral psychological and
physiological means not only is Aaliyah
a great teacher she is a much
sought-after speaker as well welcome
aaliah thanks for being
here thanks Matt it's great to be here
great let's go ahead and get started to
begin what are mindsets and how do they
influence our actions and ways of being
we Define mindsets as core assumptions
that we have about domains or categories
of things that Orient us to a particular
set of
expectations uh
explanations and goals so to put that a
little bit more simply mindsets are you
know ways of viewing reality that shape
what we expect what we understand and
what we want want to do aha that sounds
pretty
all-encompassing you know when it comes
to communication Stress and Anxiety Loom
really large be it delivering a
presentation giving constructive
feedback or answering questions what
Insight does your work on stress provide
to those of us suffering from
communication anxiety and stress around
speaking Yeah so a lot of people know
people have been studying Stress and
Anxiety for over a Century now from an
academic standpoint of course we've
always experienced Stress and Anxiety to
some degree and by and large what theyve
focused on is you know when it comes to
the psychology of stress is what people
call appraisal so how do you appraise or
think about the stressor and your
ability to handle it so do you view a
conflict or a challenging situation or
an important presentation or an
important meeting as a threat uh
something that you don't have the you
know resources to overcome or a
challenge uh something that's difficult
but you do have the resources to
overcome those sort of appraisals uh
have shown to be really important in
shaping how we show up and how we
perform in stressful situations our work
on mindset goes a little bit deeper into
the Mind into understanding not just
sort of how we appraise a particular
situation
but what are our core assumptions about
the nature of stress itself the nature
of a challenging situation um or you
know a demand in our life um that's what
we've been focused on and what we found
is that if you kind of go back into
those core assumptions what you realize
is that most people have the mindset
that stressful situations are inherently
debilitating they're going to ultimately
make us sick make us struggle make us
crumble under
pressure and when you look at the truth
about stress stress which is like most
things very complicated you realize that
that is a simplified assumption it's not
necessarily wrong but it's only one way
of viewing stress and you start to
realize that the true nature of stress
is more complex and in fact there's a
whole other side of stress that reveals
to us that the body stress response the
Mind stress response was not designed to
be debilitating but instead designed to
be uh to help us Elevate our performance
and behavior to meet the demands we're
facing there's a whole side of stress
that shows that it can have enhancing
qualities on our cognitive functioning
our physical health and on how we behave
and interact with others and so so our
work is not necessarily to find out the
truth of stress what is or what isn't
but to look at how our mindsets the core
assumptions we make about it shape how
we respond in stressful situations and
what we've shown is that if we can get
people to open their minds to this
notion that stress can be enhancing that
stress can help you rise to a newer
level of understanding can deepen your
connection with others can make us even
physiologically grow tougher and
stronger having that Focus shifts our
attention and behaviors and ways that
make that mindset more
true wow so simply by seeing what's
behind our stress beliefs and refocusing
that we can actually be empowered by our
stress rather than being negatively
affected by it is is that what I heard
you say exactly and and what's
interesting about that is you know you
wonder you might ask you know well where
does this mindset that stress is
debilitating come from you know not
surprisingly it comes from public health
messaging and
communication warning us about the
negative effects of stress and that's
not you know uh malicious that wasn't
meant to be malicious it was meant to be
helpful that messaging was meant to warn
us so that we could avoid or you know
counteract these potentially negative
effects of stress the irony is though
that messaging actually might shape
mindsets which actually makes those
debilitating effects more likely so you
know that's sort of you know when when I
started working on this we realized wow
you know maybe we're going about this
all wrong uh you know how do we help
people thrive and function under stress
it's not to tell them that it's bad for
them and they should avoid it or you
know rise above it or cope with it it's
to help them realize that stress is
natural stress is inevitable when you're
living a life that's connected with you
know things you care about right and
learning how to embrace it learning how
to work with it is really what helps us
Thrive and grow and perform at our
highest level so let me let me put you
on the spot let's say uh I am somebody
who has a big upcoming presentation or a
meeting contribution I'm getting nervous
what could I do in terms of my mindset
to help me feel a little less nervous
and perhaps even more excited about the
opportunity the steps to change your
mindsets are you know at least as as we
teach are as follows the first is to
acknowledge that you're
stressed right so you have an upcoming
uh meeting or presentation that you're
given it's important just acknowledge
that you're stressed I'm stressed about
this right and also become sorry goad I
was gonna say and it's and it's normal
to be stressed about it most people
would be exactly notice that it's normal
so acknowledging means yeah
acknowledging without judgment right
knowing just
noticing what you're feeling right how
do you respond to stress is it you know
hype getting you know hyperactives and
you know your sweaty palms or is it you
know for me sometimes it's like I I have
a big presentation or talk and I just
get all of a sudden I'm
exhausted I perspire and blush that's my
big thing I I start dripping with
sweat yes so noticing the physiological
reactions noticing your emotional
reactions noticing your behavioral
responses without judgment that's the
first step the second step is to welcome
your stress so why the heck would we
welcome your stress well it goes back to
what I just talked about we only stress
about things that we care about and so
inherently underneath the stress is a
True Value a true care a true purpose
and we wouldn't be in this situation if
it wasn't for something that mattered or
we wouldn't be stressed about it if it
wasn't for something that mattered so
that step involves basically just asking
yourself or or completing the sentence
right I'm stressed about X this upcoming
presentation because I care about why
and what is the
why right so it's the goal that you're
trying to achieve or the change you're
trying to affect that's the why exactly
I care about it because I you know
really feel like I have something
important to say that could improve the
lives of the people I'm communicating to
or could change the way we're doing
things at this company or could you know
alter
fundamentally you know the relationship
that I have with this loved one right
these These are the wise right and you
know you got to go deeper in asking the
why we call it sort of the downward
arrows of
wise you know sometimes people are like
well I'm stressed about this
presentation because like I don't want
to screw it up right well well why don't
you want to screw it up well I don't
want to screw it up because I don't want
to get fired it's like well why don't
you want to get fir you know right I
don't want to get fired because I feel
like I have a a contribution to make
here because I you know there's
something in here that I feel that I
really have to to offer you you go until
it becomes a it resonates at that
positive level for
you that's the second step so first
acknowledge your stressed second welcome
your stressed as being linked with
something you care about reconnect with
what you care about and the third is to
use or utilize your stress in ways that
help address the purpose address that
why rather than spending all your time
money effort energy trying to avoid or
get rid of the stress right so you start
to realize oh you could go back to those
Behavioral or emotional responses you
identified in step one like you know you
get flushed or you start you know
getting jittery you know I start kind of
getting tired it's like okay well
sometimes physiological responses you
can't change but oftentimes the
behavioral responses you can right maybe
you know you start you know snapping at
your spouse or your kids or something
then you real or you start you know
getting anxious and talking really fast
and you realize okay well that's not
serving my purpose of the underlying
value which is to really communicate uh
this important thing that I have to
share so the third step is really
utilizing your stress to address the
core uh value or you know purpose
underlying that stress so those are
three steps that we share with people to
help them to get into this mindset that
stress can be enhancing that the
experience of stress can help us rise to
a higher level of communication and
performance and
existence that is really powerful and
very specific and thank you and it it
avoids the checking out and the freaking
out and and allows you to harness the
stress to support the goal that you're
trying to achieve I think that's
fantastic so let's switch gears a little
bit in in our roles As Leaders teachers
caregivers and mentors what are some
things we can do to help those we work
with to develop more adaptive
mindsets ah it's such a good question
you know I I'm a mother of a
three-year-old she just turned three and
so
congratulations thank you made it three
years yes um it's been such a you know a
joy and also a challenge it's you know
raising a
human I have two teenagers believe me I
know yeah so certainly we have lots to
talk about and you start to
realize you know coming from the work
that I've done up into this point that
so much of
parenting or lead leadership you know if
we equate to that revolves around trying
to get people to do something yeah to
change their behavior you know oh you
know sigy that's you need to eat more
vegetables right or you need to go to
bed at an earlier time where you know
you need to stop frying right and it's
all focused around getting them to
change their behavior and what I've been
trying to do at least in applying my
academic and intellectual research to my
personal life is to realize that it's
ultimately not about the behavior maybe
it is at the end of the day but what if
we could think about setting and not
even changing but setting mindsets for
them that help them adopt adaptive
behaviors on their own accord right so
what is the deeper mindset that you know
exists in her mind or in anyone's mind
that is leing them to engage in a
behavior that might not be the the
appropriate one or the useful one and
what would be a more adaptive mindset to
so instead of trying to get my
three-year-old to eat broccoli because
she
should what can I do to shape her
mindset about the nature of healthy
foods and then you realize oh you know
all these tactics hey you need to eat
your broccoli before you can have your
ice cream are actually reinforcing the
mindset that those are the less tasty
less appealing things to eat right so
what can I do in my communication as a
parent or as a leader to help shape
adaptive mindset and focus on that more
than the kind of how do we persuade
somebody to do something we want to do
you know going back to the stress thing
this is really important because a lot
of parents and a lot of leaders try to
sort of shelter people away from stress
and I think we need to to rethink that
approach and open help open our kids and
our you know employees Minds to the
power of of embracing stress talking
about it embracing conflict talking
about it and so for now calie up there
of course you know that doesn't mean
purposely seeking out more stress it
doesn't laying on you know ex chores for
your children to do or
excess work yeah
but you know given that we're inevitably
going to experience stress anyways how
can we Embrace that and how can we help
shift mindsets about that first and
foremost rather than harping on their
behaviors wow that really helps me
reframe some of the things I did when I
was leading the teams I led in the
corporate world I I definitely took that
approach of my job is to shelter protect
prioritize and I see now reflection
given your insights that it would have
been much better for me to engage them
in discussions of how to better handle
the stress PRI and look at the way we're
approaching it uh rather than just
trying to deflect and defend them uh so
thank you for
that so you yourself Aaliyah are a very
accomplished speaker as evidenced by
your Ted Talk you have over four million
views people are really gravitating
towards what you talk about can you
share with us how you prepare practice
and and present so
successfully yeah it's interesting um
you know with that that Ted Talk
I I just knew I had something to say
right you know I think why it's been
successful if it's been successful is
that it came from a place of true like
authentic this is really what I want to
say and really believe in this and I
believe in the the value that this has
for people in their lives the funny
thing about that Ted Talk is I you know
I went into it and I was all prepared
and I you really worked on it hard and I
got up on that stage and I was so
nervous right I was just like and for me
you know my you know physiological
tendency with anxiety especially with
communication as my voice starts to to
quiver and shake so I could notice that
it that was happening right while I was
was doing that and you know what got me
through to the end was just to stay
connected to the why that I was up there
why I was doing this um connecting with
the the real sort of at least power and
the message that I felt I had to share
and you know it's it's interesting
because I think you know I was like
devastated after delivered it oh my God
I totally screwed it up I was like
anxious I this and that but in the end
you know it's okay and if some you know
anxiety seeps through that's also
authentic in showing that I really cared
about it I really cared about doing a
good job yeah as somebody who has done
talks like that and has coached many
people who have done talks like that you
did a fantastic job and and you're right
you come off as very authentic you
certainly come off as confident and it
sounds like putting your purpose first
and and knowing that you had something
of value to contribute to the audience
uh helped you get through that and and
it comes through for sure so I encourage
everybody to take a look at it it really
reinforces many of the points that we've
talked about so before we end I'd like
to ask you the same three questions I
ask everyone who joins me are you up for
that of course yeah all right so
question number one if you were to
capture the best communication advice
you ever received as a five to seven
word presentation slide title what would
it
[Music]
be be
yourself your best
self I like that it's very empowering
and encouraging do you find that a
mantra like that helps
you I do I you know I
actually I so my father taught um he was
a iido master he taught meditation and
then he became a um a public speaker and
communicator on conflict and Peak
Performance and what I do is actually
what what he teaches which is a a
three-step process of getting centered
present connecting to your highest
value uh and your sort of qualities that
you want to exhibit and then the third
third piece is being open to the mystery
uh which is you know yes you have a
purpose you have a why here you have a
need to present and connect and share
something but also you have so much to
learn and there's so much to be gained
from just being open in a situation so
it's you know that balance between being
present being powerful and having a
sense of confidence and conviction but
also being open to the
mystery that's cool so many people think
of communication in particular as as one
way they communicating with the audience
but there's a lot that you can learn and
being open is fantastic but let me move
on to question number two so question
two who is a communicator that you
admire and
why well you know I'd have to say you
know my dad I just mentioned that a lot
of what I employ in my life to you know
be a good
communicator be you know as high
functioning I can comes from my
upbringing and learning from him around
centering working with energy and
connecting to one's highest purpose and
he you know he was a masterful
communicator he's just a great
Storyteller but I think what made him
most powerful was just how authentic he
was and how he really came from a place
of wanting
to help people people you know be their
best selves and so I really you know
I've learned a lot from him and admire
him it sounds to me like energy presence
authenticity openness are are all
characteristics of your father and his
communication approach and you can
certainly see that in the way you
approach your
communication let me ask you question
number three what are the three
essential ingredients that go into a
successful communication
recipe be present be
yourself but be your B self right
connect to really what matters really
what you care about what are you
actually trying to do here that's a
value right that's what I mean by being
your best self and the third piece is be
open uh we're we're great communicators
only to the extent that we're really
able to listen and learn and be flexible
in the way we think um in our
assumptions and abilities to communicate
I think those three ingredients are key
and perhaps they're they're
everything I I would agree I think those
three ingredients sum up nicely
everything people need to do to not just
be a good communicator but just to be a
good person as well well Aaliyah thank
you so much uh I am completely
fascinated by the work you do and and
the impact that it can have app uh
you're clearly very passionate and
articulate about it thank you so much
for sharing specific things we can all
do to adopt and support positive
mindsets thank you thanks Matt it was so
fun and I look forward to talking more
about all of this excellent me too thank
you for listening to think fast talk
smart the podcast a production of
Stamford Graduate School of Business to
learn more go to gb. stanford.edu
please download other episodes wherever
you find your
podcasts